[Music]  i have been  lying on my resume that i was a double  major  ever since i graduated college and that  i had a 3.5 gpa  it was definitely not the case more of  like a c student  so a couple years ago my  great-grandmother  passed away after the ceremony my  grandmother  took my great-grandmother's ashes and  went  to where my great-grandfather's ashes  were and she put them in the same grave  which was ironic because they got  divorced when my grandma was 10.  so she didn't tell anybody about it  but it was her last act of trying to get  them back together  [Music]  i just decided that i need to leave my  husband  i'm trying to leave but i can't  [Music]